[Música]
a tecnologia transformou a minha vida
essa sou eu um ano de idade meu primeiro
computador pequenininha já adorava mexer
em tudo
meus pais me educaram até os 8 anos de
idade
minha mãe me ensinou na escola da vida
mas ela sempre perdia muito tempo no
banco e eu adorava brincar de banco e
sempre esperava ansiosa por ela com os
papéis de depósito
eu falava mãe não precisa perder tanto
tempo no banco quando crescer eu vou
montar o banco dos bancos
e aí você pode fazer tudo num só
mas é um banco que eu cobrava juros do
banco um pouco diferente que dava que
não tirava cresci com isso em mente mas
aos 12 anos de idade foi onde tudo
começou
meus pais sofreu um acidente de carro
foi aí que eu tive que me virar lei que
pela primeira vez a tecnologia salvou a
minha vida foi onde eu comecei a fazer
website meu primeiro website
eu não vendi eu fiz de graça 3 um
restaurante
aí eu fui no vizinho no concorrente e
falei olha o seu vizinho tem um website
e só 18 anos atrás da nossa senhora
falou tá bom tá bom eu insistia tanto
que ele não eu pegava um
cartão-de-visita falava não está muito
feio consigo fazer melhor
se eu fizer bonito você me paga e assim
eu comecei sendo empreendedora para
sobreviver
foi muito difícil tive que amadurecer
com criança muito rápido e sem
empreendedora no brasil não é fácil como
mulher ainda mais difícil
enfrentei muitos obstáculos um deles o
acesso ao crédito
o segundo a partir de mentoria suporte e
apoio que precisava
quero respeito no trabalho e nas
relações com a mulher que trabalhava às
vezes cinco vezes mais do que o colega
homem para me destacar e também o acesso
à inovação
mas eu fiz de sistemas do governo irá
monitorar hidrelétricas jogos e
aplicativos
cresci muito amadureci quebra a empresa
construir de novo cair levantei cair de
novo levantei e quem sempre estava ali
do meu lado para me inspirar
era o meu pai meu pai conseguiu inovar
num lugar chamado governo ali em 1996
ele criou um programa chamado pronaf eo
programa nacional da agricultura
familiar
esse programa dava acesso à oportunidade
às pessoas na área rural e ajudou também
todo o sistema e cooperativo a crescer
isso me inspirou muito mais o governo
era difícil a gente via a burocracia
a gente viu tanto que demorava para o
agricultor ter acesso a uma um caixa
eletrônico 100 quilômetros em média
empréstimos como o governo demoravam
cerca de 120 dias para serem liberados
muita coisa ea média quando ia para um
banco privado e até hoje é mais ou menos
de 143 por cento de taxa de juros anuais
é muito caro e isso quando você não
precisa de algo emergencial é porque vai
ver você quebra uma máquina lhe que
precisa para irrigar o café e se você
não rigatti o café naquela data você
perde a safra do ano inteiro aí você vai
pra onde cartão de crédito
aí sim os juros são de 1.000 a 3.000 por
cento e quando você não paga o mínimo e
aí vira uma bola de neve
então na realidade quem está nessa
situação de ou não tem uma conta
bancária
outra com o nome negativado são 80
milhões de brasileiros 3 milhões
passando fome então descobrir na
tecnologia um meio de ajudar o meio de
conectar as pessoas
e foi daí que surgiu a moeda que a moeda
a moeda mais comum que a gente conhece
hoje essa nota mas ele vai tirar essa
nota aqui ela não tem dono ela não tem o
meu nome não está escrito treinar aqui
seu delas é essa nota para o mendigo na
rua eu não sei se ele vai comprar
cachaça
você vai ajudar a família mas imagina se
a essa nota
eu consigo anexar a minha identidade
se eu consigo anexar a minha identidade
a essa nota ela já tem um valor
ela já consegue ser transferida mas
imagina que eu posso ex há também essa
nota essa identidade um contrato que eu
sabia exatamente onde eu vou gastar esse
dinheiro então posso mandar esses cem
reais para a áfrica e eu sei que estou
ajudando que médico que estou ajudando
que criança que estou ajudando com
medicamentos ou comprando
então pensando nisso e agregar o
dinheiro valor do dinheiro agregar
identidade agregar um contrato que você
vê o poder do box to box tinha um
protocolo hoje é uma das tecnologias de
ponta no mundo
vocês vão ouvir falar bastante do golpe
em um bloquinho eu posso ir além do
maior caso de sucesso do botinha foi o
bitcoin quando você consegue fazer uma
transação financeira o do outro lado do
mundo em segundos passar o dinheiro e
você tem a sua identidade seu endereço
sua assinatura atrelada a ele então ali
você não precisa de um intermediário
intermediário banco porque o banco cobra
muito caro pra falar que eu só treinar
que eu sou dona do meu dinheiro que você
é dono do seu dinheiro
as taxas são absurdas e o tempo nem se
fala
então imagina que ao contrato a gente
possa anexar também objetivos e metas
para serem cumpridas
esses são os objetivos do
desenvolvimento sustentável das nações
unidas onde todos nós aqui temos
responsabilidade
ajudar a combater a fome a pobreza a
criar mais igualdade de gênero
imagina se tudo isso a gente consegue
colocar uma caixa no bloco e consegue
que esse bloco tenha esse cadeado seja
um bloco transparente e essa informação
não pode ser deletada
esse é o poder do blog chin você não
pode deletar as informações todas elas
são compartilhados de forma transparente
e com isso a gente vencer uma batalha
muito grande que a batalha que esse país
sofre de mais que a batalha da corrupção
eu construí a minha carreira lá fora
porém nova york em londres na suécia
não foi fácil não foi fácil ouvir os
meus colegas que a não investir no país
não seu país tenta muito bagunçado
política lá o que está acontecendo
presidente o que é isso
falava poxa não quero isso
como é que a gente faz para mudar como é
que a gente faz para conectar as pessoas
do bem para dar voz às pessoas do bem e
aí que eu vi o poder da transparência
que a gente precisa de uma revolução
tecnológica mais uma revolução da
confiança das pessoas poderem acreditar
que sim existem pessoas boas no nosso
país que estão fazendo a diferença é que
elas merecem crédito e acesso a mentoria
ter respeito e ter acesso à inovação
agora você imagina que pessoas do outro
lado do mundo possam se conectar as
pessoas aqui no brasil
na moeda nós tivemos cerca de 841
investidores em sua maioria chineses
o engraçado é que entre a maioria
chineses entre os 20 e 28 anos de idade
jovens investindo em projetos daqui do
brasil de mulheres agora entender do
hras nas áreas rurais que agora sim tem
voz
então a capacidade de conectar a
capacidade de criar essa confiança
esse laço de purificar ajudou a dar voz
às nossas empreendedoras de um estudo
grande do banco mundial que fala sobre o
grameen bank sobre a a a questão do
hummer yunus é o banco do povo que prova
que as mulheres são boas pagadoras as
mulheres pensam em longo prazo pensam em
gerações então elas conseguem ali
multiplicar o dinheiro multiplicar o
impacto desse dinheiro a maioria da
renda vai para a família 80% da renda
que investir revestida investida na
família quando o dinheiro está na mão de
uma mulher ea gente sabe que o para o
país
nosso brasil é um país machista a mulher
trabalha mas é um homem que fica ali no
caixa na carteira
a gente tem que mudar essa realidade em
poderá a mulher a mulher que está do
nosso lado e você imagina se pra mim foi
difícil que cresci na cidade
fui morar fora imagina para um
empreendedor na área rural de acesso a
crédito a essa rede não foi pensando
nisso que eu enxerguei que a tecnologia
podia dar voz a essas mulheres para nos
contarem a história delas
quem melhor que elas pra contar a
própria história e para ter acesso
direto ao investidor sem nenhum
intermediário para contar quanto que
elas vão impactar com aquele dinheiro e
pra gente audita o processo inteiro de
forma transparente utilizando tecnologia
então o investidor vai ver desde o
início desde a criação do plano de
negócios até a disponibilização do
crédito crédito vai voltar o impacto vai
acontecer mudanças bom ser geradas italy
registrado no banco também de
conhecimento pra não reinventar mais a
roda que contar que a história do dona
divina
dona divina de formosa goiás
ela me mata de orgulho meu pai há dez
anos atrás conseguiu fundar a cooperar
primeira cooperativa dela é uma
cooperativa de produção onde ela juntava
os cooperados pra processar época de
fruta para acolher barueri e ela
meio de formosa 100 quilômetros do do
banco conseguiu impactar 170 famílias
nesses dez anos que ela ajuda a gente
foi lá e foi além
porque não é só ensinar a pescar hoje
ensinar a pescar dá o peixe ajudar a
vender o peixe é isso que faz a
diferença então a gente foi lá no
governo conversamos com o prefeito não
vamos vender diretamente seu produto
aqui pra as escolas estão com isso a
gente conseguiu contratos para ela então
ela vai ter uma garantia de receita
então gerar emprego e renda
penso que meu pai me ensinou sempre tem
que ajudar a pessoa a crescer de forma
independente as próprias pernas então
com os investimentos a produção dela
cresceu cinco vezes e ela está feliz
porque agora com a tecnologia e com ela
tendo essa possibilidade de contar a
história
são menos intermediários ela vende um
pacote de baru a r$5 vendia para outra
pessoa que vende para um atravessador
que vem dia pro outro trabalhador e
chegava lá no mercado
o saquinho desse tamanho r$7 r$8 então
que ela perdia no processo a gente
conector dona divina com muito mais
gente e é o poder não só do crédito
agora o poder da rede quando a gente
conecta as pessoas certas a gente
consegue multiplicar então com os
intermediários
ela perdia muito indo diretamente
hoje ela pode vender uma gotinha do óleo
de barulho e botar um produto de cabelo
e esse produto é vendido por 50 reais
então o poder da tecnologia o poder do
marketing o poder da nossa moeda
nossa moeda é a moeda da transparência
porque é muito fácil às vezes a gente
julgar mas quando a gente julga
é um paradoxo a gente julga uma pessoa
aponta um dedo falar o programa do
governo problema da copa corrupção
a gente esquece que tem três dedos aqui
apontados para nós que a gente está
fazendo contato também a história da
sandra é catarinense de chapecó nossa
sandra uma super mulher super guerreira
ela juntou muito dinheiro não foi
juntando um pouquinho a vilã o edital do
governo para comprar uma máquina de
pasteurização de leite e ela corria nu
um banco que tinha um outro edital
participava para comprar outra máquina
ela conseguiu montar toda a estrutura de
uma fábrica de leite mas o principal ela
não conseguiu que foi o capital de giro
mas também tem um problema que tem
dinheiros para muitas coisas
desconectadas
mas o principal pra você rodar sua
empresa lhe durante 60 dias não tem o
dinheiro sai caro estão disponibilizando
dinheiro para sandra agora que ela
fabrica imensa que ela conseguiu botar
de pé que estava parada vai rodar
então a gente vê que é simples e está
dentro de cada um que a tecnologia que a
gente tem hoje possibilita cada um de
nós transformar o que a gente precisa é
a revolução da cooperação vamos cooperar
para que cada mulher do nosso lado seja
ponderada para que cada um seja tocado e
que a gente transforme juntos muitas
vidas
meu pai ninguém sabe por que ele nunca
divulgava mas ele ajudou diretamente 3
milhões de pessoas com os programas ali
tentando inovar dentro do governo mas
era tudo ilimitado
minha meta é um pouco mais ambiciosa com
tecnologia e com o apoio de cada um
daqui e de lá do outro lado do mundo da
china e de todos os outros países que
estão dispostos a ajudar as mulheres
guerreiras aqui do país ea meta são 3
bilhões
a gente vai conseguir juntos vai demorar
um tempo para cada um acordar o coração
para cada um deixar em vez de deixar o
dinheiro ali no banco parado na poupança
que vai render o que 5% poder investir
na dona divina na dona sandra na dona
maria e ter 5% 8% mudar o conceito do
que é investir para investir em pessoas
obrigado
[Aplausos]